seit mehreren Monaten befindet sich der
Nahe Osten wieder in Aufruhe der
Konflikt zwischen Israel und der Hamas
beherrscht seit Oktober die Schlagzeilen
die Welt ist in Alarmbereitschaft und
die Großmächte sind es noch mehr US
Militäreinsatz zur Verhinderung der
Ausbreitung des Konflikts im Nahen Osten
2000 Soldaten zwei Flugzeugträger und
135 Kampfjets china hat bis zu sechs
Kriegsschiffe im Nahen Osten stationiert
da die Spannungen durch den Krieg
zwischen Israel und Gaza zunehmen der
iranische Außenminister warnt Israel von
Beirut aus die Angriffe auf den
Gazastreifen einzustellen oder ein
großes Erdbeben zu riskieren aber kommt
es euch nicht auch so vor dass seit
Beginn des Konflikts ein Teil in diesem
komplexen Puzzle fehlt was passiert mit
der größten arabischen macht im Nahen
Osten was ist in Saudi-Arabien los das
saudische Regime meine Lieben Zuschauer
ist in einer besonders heiklen Lage
einerseits ist dieser Konflikt eine
besonders schlechte Nachricht für seine
wirtschaftlichen Wachstumspläne und zwar
einschließlich seiner geopolitischen und
strategischen Interessen außerdem lauert
der Schatten des Irans in der Region und
Saudi-Arabien ist klar wenn die Hamas
gewinnt gewinnt auch der Iran infolge
dessen weisen viele Analysten bereits
auf die Möglichkeit hin dass
Saudi-Arabien sehlichst auf einen
schnellen Sieg Israels in diesem
Konflikt hofft alles was wir sehen
deutet darauf hin dass genau dies der
Fall ist aber da ist noch mehr welche
wirtschaftlichen Interessen hat z.B der
Saud Regime dass es sich so sehr die
Niederlage der Hamas herbeiwischt warum
wäre ein Sieg der Hamas auch ein Sieg
für den Iran könnte ein Erfolg der Hamas
den Konflikt zwischen den Saudis und den
Hut die im Yemen eskalieren lassen heute
werden wir all diese spannenden Fragen
natürlich beantworten und zwar gleich
nach der knackigen Werbebotschaft
unseres Sponsors blinkest denn die
Berliner Firma blinkest hat mit ihrem
Beitrag nicht nur das heutige Video
möglich gemacht nein wir selbst nutzen
Ihre App auch um täglich unseren eigenen
Wissenshorizont zu erweitern vielleicht
fragt ihr euch ja manchmal wie wir es
schaffen so viel Wissen aus
verschiedenen Bereichen miteinander in
unseren Videos zu verknüpfen nun der
Schlüssel dazu ist vor allem lesen lesen
und manchmal auch hören Artikel Analysen
Videos Podcasts und vor allem Bücher mit
Grundlagen wissen das notwendig ist um
all diese Informationen zu einem
Gesamtbild verknüpfen zu können aber was
wenn man gar nicht die Zeit dazu hat so
viele verschiedene Bücher zu lesen nun
genau dann ist man bei blinkist richtig
denn es verschafft einem nicht nur mehr
Zeit sondern motiviert auch noch durch
die unterhaltsame Aufmachung Blinkis
bringt das Wichtigste aus mehr als 5000
Sachbüchern und Podcasts auf dein Handy
und dann erlebst du einen ungeahnten
wissensboost anstatt Stunden in die
Lektüre eines Buches zu stecken und es
dann vielleicht gar nicht zu Ende zu
lesen ziehst du dir in null, nichts die
immer sehr angenehm und locker
geschriebene blinkist Verion rein man
merkt dass da echte Profis und Talente
am Werk sind stell dir vor wir würden
ein wertvolles aber langes Buch in ein
knackiges und leicht verdauliches
visualpolitik Video Gießen undun genau
das macht blinkist ein Beispiel sind
Bücher von Autoren mit denen man
vielleicht nicht immer einer Meinung ist
womit aber kann man sein Horizont besser
weitern als mit Informationen die eben
nicht aus der eigenen buabbel stammen
mir ist z.B das Buch kein Kapitalismus
ist auch keine Lösung der ehemaligen Tat
Autorin Ulrike Hermann aufgefallen auch
hier habe ich mir gesagt h die Tatz ist
nicht gerade mein Leib und magenblatt
Rezensenten auf Amazon haben das Buch
auch dafür kritisiert langatmig zu sein
muss ich mir das also wirklich antun
andererseits hat mich schon interessiert
was da drin steht tja und dank der
Fesseln geschriebenen blinkistfassung
konnte ich innerhalb von 25 Minuten
herausfinden dass dieses Werk zumindest
in dieser blinkest Version mein Horizont
durchaus bereichern konnte solides
Wissen dass ich ohne blinkes sicher
verpasst hätte kurz gesagt diese App
wird mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit auch
dein Leben bereichern egal für welches
Thema du dich gerade interessierst die
Auswahl und das Spektrum sind wirklich
riesig von Finanzen über Wissenschaft
Politik Karriere bis zu den klassischen
Ratgeberthemen um sein Leben zu
optimieren aber man kann mit Blinkis
nicht nur sich selbst sondern auch seine
Lieben bereichern es hat nämlich vor
kurzem eine ganz neue Funktion namens
blinkes spaces eingeführt damit kannst
du deine lieblingsblinks mit deinen
Freunden und Kollegen teilen und
diskutieren wie in in einem Buchclub das
coole daran ist dass du blinkest basic
User in deinen space einladen kannst und
diese dort dann alle Titel lesen und
hören können auch wenn sie normalerweise
nur für Premium Mitglieder zugänglich
wären und das ist noch nicht alles als
visualpolitik Zuschauer bekommst du über
den Link in der Beschreibung nicht nur
zwei Mitgliedschaften zum Preis von
einer sondern oben drein noch 25% Rabatt
auf blinkist Premium also zögere nicht
besorg dir jetzt gleich die kostenlose 7
Tage Testversion über den Link unter
diesem Video und fang gleich damit an
deinen Wissenschatz zu bereichern und
wenn du das erledigt hast können wir
sofort zur be wortung unserer spannenden
Fragen schreiten
aufgepasst Verhandlung auf
[Musik]
abpruf nur wenige Wochen vor dem Angriff
der Hamas auf Israel am 7 Oktober 2033
waren Saudi-Arabien und Israel dabei das
Abkommen abzuschließen dass ihre
politischen und wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen ein für alle Mal
normalisieren sollte die Verhandlungen
wurden stark von der beiden Regierung
gefördert 3 Jahre nach dem berühmten
Abraham Abkommen das Israel dazu brachte
mehreren arabischen Staaten die Hand zu
reichen aber dieses sollte nur den
Anfang darstellen der Teil nämlich der
von Washington und auch vor allem von
Premierminister Netanyahu am meisten
verfolgt wurde war die Einigung mit Riad
das arabische Land war seinerseits sehr
daran interessiert von den
wirtschaftlichen und militärischen
Vorteilen zu profitieren die die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate seit der
Unterzeichnung des abrahamabkommens
bereits genießen um welche Vorteile es
sich handelt nun in erster Linie der
Zugang zur florierenden und hochgradig
innovativ israelischen Wirtschaft vor
allem zur israelischen Hochtechnologie
und natürlich neben alldem zur
Erreichung der langersehnten und
notwendigen regionalen Stabilität und
das alles geschieht zu einer Zeit in der
Saudi-Arabien besonders auf die
Diversifizierung seiner Wirtschaft
bedacht ist behaltet bitte im Hinterkopf
dass die Haupteinnahmequelle des Landes
im Moment immer noch der Ölexport ist um
diese Abhängigkeit ein für alle Mal zu
überwinden fördert die größte arabische
macht mit ihrer Vision 2030 Strategie
eine Reihe von Mega Projekten die im
Grunde eine Art Mission Impossible
darstellen eine Mission Impossible in
der Wüste denn wir reden hier meine
Lieben Zuschauer über echte megaprjekte
von denen ihr sicher alle schon gehört
habt the line die surreale Wüstenstadt
die in Saudi-Arabien bereits gebaut wird
neom will den weltgrößten schwimmenden
Industriekomplex oxagon errichten mit
diesen Projekten will Saudi-Arabien
seine Wirtschaft weniger angreifbar und
anfällig machen doch um sie zu
verwirklichen und zum Erfolg zu führen
ist dem Regime eines klar es braucht
unbedingt Stabilität in der
Region und das Abkommen dass sie mit
Israel und den USA ausgehandelt hatten
war entscheidend um dieses Ziel zu
erreichen doch egal wie weit die
Verhandlungen fortgeschritten waren es
gab immer noch große Hindernisse die
Wahrheit ist dass sich die saudischen
Forderungen als echte Herausforderung
für das Überleben der Verhandlungen
selbst erwiesen haben so verlangte das
arabische Regime unter anderem dass die
USA sich zur vollständigen Verteidigung
ihres gesamten Territoriums verpflichten
darüber hinaus gaben sie ihren Wunsch
nicht auf ihre zivile nukleare
Infrastruktur mit amerikanischer Hilfe
zu entwickeln und sie forderten in enger
Abstimmung mit der sogenannten
palästinensischen Autonomiebehörde dass
Israel die weitere Besiedlung des
Westjordanlands beendet Washington
seinerseits forderte von Riad die
Erdölproduktion zu erhöhen um der
Weltwirtschaft unter die Arme zu greifen
mit anderen Worten auf dem Tisch lag
nicht nur das Abkommen mit Israel
sondern auch die großangelegte
Neuauflage des amerikanischsudischen
verteidigungspakts und im Grunde eine
neue OPEC Energie die Politik wir
sprechen also nicht von einem Abkommen
das einfach zu erreichen war dennoch
machten die Verhandlungen trotz aller
Unstimmigkeiten Fortschritte alle drei
Länder wussten nur zu gut dass sich
durch dieses Abkommen viel zu gewinnen
hatten die USA könnten ein Gegengewicht
zum wachsenen Einfluss Chinas im Nahen
Osten schaffen Israel könnte einen
großen Schritt zur Beendigung der
historischen arabisch-israelischen
Spannungen machen und Riad könnte die
Region stabilisieren den schuts der USA
genießen und mit Israel einen mächtigen
neuen Wirtschafts und Technologiepartner
gewinnen und so Schritten die
Verhandlungen trotz aller
Unstimmigkeiten endlich mit vollldampf
voran am 7 Oktober allerdings kam der
brutale hamasangriff und Tage später
ging alles den Bach runter Saudi-Arabien
pausiert die normalisierungsgespräche
mit Israel inmitten des andauernden
Krieges gegen die Hamas tatsächlich
behauptete die beiden Regierung dass die
Hamas Israel genau deshalb angegriffen
habe um die Verhandlungen zwischen den
drei Ländern zum Scheitern zu bringen
einer der Gründe warum sie so gehandelt
haben warum die Hamas gegen Israel
vorgegangen ist war dass sie wussten
dass ich mich mit den Saudis
zusammensetzen würde denn die Saudis
wollten Israel anerkennen und das würde
den Nahen Osten tatsächlich Vereinen Joe
Biden am 20 Oktober 2023 nun ja die
Realität ist dass der hamasangriff die
Pläne tatsächlich durchkreuzt hat
Saudi-Arabien jongliert jetzt mit seinen
Optionen um zu verhindern dass sie alle
zwischen seinen Fingern zerinnen wie
Wüstensand
der
Balanceakt die Anschläge der Hamas haben
auf internationaler Ebene ein
politisches Erdbeben ausgelöst bei dem
sich die Länder auf die eine oder die
andere Seite geschlagen haben sicherlich
werden euch die Position der westlichen
Länder sowie Chinas und Russlands am
meisten in Erinnerung bleiben aber
natürlich haben auch die arabischen
länderstellung bezogen so Verurteilten
z.B bachrein und die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate Israels Partner seit
dem Abraham Abkommen den Angriff der
Qatar seinerseits verurteilte Israel für
sein ständigen Druck auf den
Gazastreifen und das Westjordanland aber
was ist mit Saudi-Arabien nun anders als
in früheren Fällen hatte es nicht den
Luxus sich zwischen Schwarz und Weiß
entscheiden zu können es entschied sich
daher für ein Spiel mit den Grautönen
während es einen dauerhaften
Waffenstillstand und die Förderung der
zwei statenlösung forderte verurteilte
es sowohl den Angriff der Hamas als auch
Israels Vorgehen im Gazastreifen und im
westürdernland und ihr fragt euch
vielleicht h war es denn nicht die Hamas
die die wirtschaftlichen Pläne des
Saudis durch kreuzt hat nun ja in der
Tat ist das so aber das reicht nicht aus
um sich klar zu Israels Gunsten zu
positionieren vergess nicht dass die
sogenannte palästinensische Sache in den
arabischen und muslimischen
Gemeinschaften nach wie vor ein
besonders sensibles Thema ist und die
saudische Gesellschaft bildet da keine
Ausnahme ganz anders sieht es allerdings
mit der Sympathie für die Hamas in
Saudi-Arabien aus diese befindet sich
nun wahrlich auf einem Tiefpunkt während
2014 noch 48% der Saudis eine positive
Einstellung Z chamas hatten sind es
dieses Jahr nur noch
10%. der Verlust der Popularität der
Hamas bei den Saudis ist kaum
überraschend schließlich hat sich
Saudi-Arabien seit der Gründung der
Hamas in den 80er Jahren stark
zurückgehalten und sich von dieser
Gruppe distanziert vergesst nicht dass
die Hamas aus einem Ableger der
Muslimbruderschaft hervorgegangen ist
die saudische Monarchie wiederum
bekämpft die Muslimbruderschaft weil sie
sie als Bedrohung für eigenes Überleben
sieht doch trotz alldessen bestand eine
Beziehung im Gegensatz zu Washington
erkannte Riad den wahsier Hamas im
Gazastreifen im Jahr 2006 tatsächlich an
ab 2012 geriet diese freundschaftliche
Beziehung allerdings ins Wanken der
arabische Frühling hatte viele arabische
Regierungen in die Schranken gewiesen
sodass das saudische Königshaus begriff
dass es sich keine Fehltritte mehr
leisten konnte so unterstützten sie z.B
einen Putsch zur Absetzung von Mohammed
morsi in Ägypten morsi war ein Mitglied
der Muslimbruderschaft und ein
führroller der Hamas relativ nahe stand
seitdem haben sich die Beziehungen
zwischen Riad und Gaza immer weiter
verschlechtert und zwar bish hin zu dem
Punkt dass die saudische Polizei Hamas
mit im Land verhaftet hat doch während
der letzten zwei Jahre haben sich
Saudi-Arabien die Hamas wieder
angenähert und ihr fragt euch warum nun
weil Riad wusste dass die Unterzeichnung
des Abkommens mit Israel nur dann
möglich war wenn eine politische Lösung
für Gaza gefunden würde und natürlich
stellten die Spannungen mit der Hamas
dafür einen großen Stolperstein da aus
diesem Grund hat das saudische Regime
Gefangene der Hamas freigelassen und
ihren Anführern erlaubt von Qatar aus
nach Mekka zu pilgern aber trotz allem
hat sich Riad immer klar ausgedrückt die
Hamas ist ein hind ist und die Frage ist
ist sie es nur deswegen weil sie den
wirtschaftlichen plän Rat schadet oder
steckt doch noch mehr dahinter nun hört
jetzt genau
zu der Iran kontrolliert das
Spiel falls ihr treue Zuschauer von
visualpolitik seid wisst ihr bereits
dass Saudi-Arabien einen besonders
unangenehmen Nachbaren hat mit dem es
schon mehrmals aneinander geraten ist
Qatar seitdem dort der Emir altani im
Jahr 1995 an die Macht gekommen ist hat
Saudi-Arabien eine angespannte Beziehung
zu diesem kleinen arabischen Land ob
wegen der Berichterstattung über den
arabischen Frühling durch den
katarischen Sender al-jasira oder wegen
der angeblichen Förderung des
islamistischen Terrorismus in der Region
Saudi-Arabien und Qatar sind alles
andere als gute Freunde tatsächlich
verhängten Saudi-Arabien zusammen mit
vielen anderen Ländern wie bachrein den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten und
Jordanien zwischen 2017 und 2021 eine
brutale Blockade gegen Qatar eine
Blockade die übrigens wie wir euch
bereits gesagt haben ein großer
Misserfolg war und jetzt könnten die
Spannungen wieder aufflammen da Qatar
erneut seine Unterstützung für die Hamas
demonstriert hat das ist auch nicht
ungewöhnlich Qatar beherbergt nämlich
seit mehr als einem Jahrzehnt sowohl
aktuelle als auch ehemalige hochrangige
Funktionäre der Hamas wie Chalet mesal
darüber hinaus hat Doha den
Terroranschlag bisher nicht verurteilt
was wnig überraschend sowohl die
Vorwürfe es sei ein Förderer des
Terrorismus als auch die Vorstellung
Qatar habe ein starkes Interesse am
Überleben der Hamas verstärkt hat
diesmal allerdings konnte Doha nicht
übermäßig streitlustig sein Washington
dass eine große Militärbasis in dem Land
unterhält hätte das nicht zugelassen und
genau das erklärt diese wichtige
Nachricht 12 dezember
2023 hamasführer verlassen Qatar mit
unbekanntem Ziel die Hauptsorge Arabien
stellt im Moment allerdings nicht Qatar
da sondern der
Iran und vielleicht denkt ihr dass die
Spannungen zwischen dies beiden Ländern
nach Nachrichten wieeder folgenden
verschwunden
sein das von China vermittelte Abkommen
stellt die naosdipomatie auf den Kopf
und fordert die USA heraus das in Peking
ausgehandelte Abkommen sowie der
Herstellung der Beziehungen zwischen
Saudi-Arabien und dem Iran signalisiert
zumindest eine vorübergehende Neuordnung
der üblichen Allianzen und Rivalitäten
wobei Washington am Rande steht
allerdings könnte nichts WE von der
Wahrheit entfernt sein der Iran und
Saudi-Arabien bleiben große regionale
Rivalen zwei Giganten die den Nahen
Osten dominieren wollen und einander
nicht vertrauen und genau an dieser
Stelle hat der Iran einen großen Vorteil
den Riad auch gerne hätte nämlich seine
Stellvertreter oder auch proxiarmeen wir
haben euch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
bereits auf diesem Kanal über sie
berichtet die hisbala ist der wichtigste
und mächtigste nichtstaatliche
Verbündete des Irans und wie ihr euch
vielleicht erinnert hat auch die Hamas
große Mengen an Geld und Waffen vom Iran
und der hisbalah erhalten doch teheran
hat noch einen weiteren Verbündeten der
normalerweise unbemerkt bleibt einen
Verbündeten direkt vor der Haustür
Saudi-Arabiens im Jemen die Rede ist
natürlich von den
huthi in den 1990er Jahren als
politische Gruppe gegründet die die
Forderungen der Saidi Muslime des Landes
kanalisieren wollte wurde sie im Lauf
der Zeit immer radikaler zwischen 2004
und 2010 kam es sogar zu mehreren
bewaffneten auseinander etzung gegen die
Regierung des Diktators Ali Abdullah
sali diesen Beschuldigten sie der
Korruption und der Unterwerfung unter
die Befehle Saudi Arabiens im Jahr 2011
spielten die hui eine wichtige Rolle bei
der Revolution im Land die mit dem Sturz
von sali und der Machtübernahme von
Mansur alhadi endete aber erst 2014
erlangten die huthi die wirkliche Macht
im Jemen im September desselben Jahres
nahmen sie Sanaa die hauptstattt des
Landes ein der Jemen wurde daraufhin in
einen Bürgerkrieg gestürzt der bis heute
andauert saudische Truppen haben direkt
in ihn eingegriffen um das Funktionieren
der meerengel BAB elmb einer wichtigen
Zone für den internationalen Transport
von Energierohstoffen sicherzustellen
allerdings führte diese Intervention
Saudi-Arabiens zu einem weiteren
schlüssselfaktor und rate mal welcher
das ist ganz genau iranische Hilfe für
die hui tatsächlich sind Nachrichten wie
die folgende seit 2011 an der
Tagesordnung 5 April 2016 die US-Marine
hat nach eigenen Angaben Waffen aus dem
Iran sichergestellt die inlich für die H
die im Jemen bestimmt sind 15 November
2022 US Navy beschlagnah 70 Tonnen
iranischen Raketentreibstoff von einem
Segelschiff im Jemen 2 Februar 2023 das
us-mitär sagt dass eine große iranische
Waffenlieferung die für jemenitische
Rebellen bestimmt war im Golf von Oman
sichergestellt wurde Saudi-Arabien und
die hui stehen seit 2015 in einem
militärischen Konflikt in diesem Krieg
sind mehr als 400.000 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen und 80 pro der jemenitischen
Bevölkerung stecken in einer schweren
humanitären
[Musik]
Krise der Konflikt verläuft heute nicht
mehr so blutig wie in den Anfangsjahren
und es wurde sogar ein vorübergehender
waffensttillstand erreicht dennoch
könnte der Konflikt zwischen Israel und
der Hamas alles wieder verändern
Nachrichten wie die folgende spiegeln
diese große Bedrohung gut wieder 8
dezember 2023 ih ansetzt auf HU die
Proxis um den Kampf mit Israel zu
eskalieren die vom Iran unterstützte
Miliz im Jemen hat drohen und
Raketenangriffe auf israelische und
amerikanische Ziele gestartet
amerikanische Amtsträger befürchten dass
die Gruppe zu weit gehen und einen
größeren Krieg ansettelen könnte 12
Januar
2023 Großbritannien bombardiert den
Jemen nachdem huirabellen Schiffe im
Roten Meer angegriffen haben das
US-amerikanische und das britische
Militär haben am Donnerstag in einem
massiven Vergeltungsschlag mehr als ein
Dutzend Einrichtungen bombardiert die
von den vom Iran unterstützten huis im
Jen genutzt wurden nach gaben mehrerer
us-amtsträger wurden tomahaw Raketen von
Kriegsschiffen und Kampfjets eingesetzt
zu den militärischen Zielen gehörten
logistische Knotenpunkte
Luftabwehrsystem und Waffenlager ein
Funktionär der huthi hat ebenfalls
bestätigt dass die Angriffe im Jemen
begonnen haben jetzt starten Amerika
Großbritannien und Israel Angriffe auf
hodaida und Sanaa sagte der hui
Generalmajor Abdul salamahf und die
große Frage ist könnte der Krieg in den
Jemen zurückkehren ein Wiederaufflammen
des Krieges im Jemen wäre für Riad ein
großer Rückschlag bedenkt bitte dass ein
Sieg der huti andere schiitische
Aufstände im Nahen Osten anfeuern könnte
und zwar sogar in Saudi-Arabien selbst
einem Land in den die schiitische
Gemeinschaft genau in den Gebieten mit
den größten Ölvorkommen ansässig ist
ganz zu schweigen davon wenn Israel zu
gegebener Zeit militärisch eingreifen
würde das würde Riad in eine wahre
Zwickmühle bringen Israel ist bereit
gegen die hui Rebellen vorzugehen wenn
die internationale Gemeinschaft es nicht
tut sagt der nationale
Sicherheitsberater ihr müsst nälich
verstehen den dass Saudi-Arabien
tatsächlich auf einen schnellen
israelischen Sieg über die Hamas hofft
ein Sieg der dieser Terrorgruppe ein für
alle Mal das Genick bricht den Einfluss
des Irans in der Region verringert und
das Abschreckung für andere Gruppen
dient aber an dieser Stelle sind die
Fragen erstmal an euch gerichtet glaubt
ihr dass Saudi-Arabien Israel offen
unterstützen wird werden wir trotz allem
was passiert ist bald ein Abkommen
zwischen Israel und Saudi-Arabien
erleben wie immer sind wir auf eure
anregende Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dies Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch ETW daraus gel hab falls
ja gibt ihm bitte ein Like Teil auch mit
euren Freunden und auf den sozialen
Medien natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
un diesprjekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung dem
Video mach's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald